In this course you'll go to the farm. The farm stack
is FastAPI, React, and GraphQL. Bek Brace will
teach you how to use this stack to make a full
stack web app. Hey, what's going on guys, this is
big breeze. I hope you're all doing well. Welcome
to the forums. That course in today's course,
the technologies that we're going to be using are
some of my favorite ones. We're going to work with
fast API, React js, and MongoDB, which are the
components of the farm stack. And you probably
have heard of this suffix stack in other terms,
like the myrn stack, which stands for MongoDB
Express, react, and Node JS. And what's meant by
stack simply is a set of technologies that you
can use together to create a web application,
for instance. So farm stands for fast API,
react, and MongoDB. And we're going to build
our app using fast API for the back end server,
React for the front end client, and MongoDB
for the backend database server. So this is for
data persistence. And in my opinion, farm stack
resembles the MEAN stack or the myrn. Stack even
The only difference is the fast API. Because react
and MongoDB are the same in the three stacks.
In Maine, we use Angular, no GS, and in
myrn, we use react and Node JS. Fast API,
of course, is a modern and fast web framework for
building API's created by Sebastian Ramirez. And
this uses ASCII. And ASCII stands for
asynchronous server gateway interface.
And this is just the interface between
your application and the server.
And the response time is lightning fast. And
this is one of the big advantages of having
as the server implementation on your side also
fast API one of its biggest features that it
supports coroutines and concurrency without the
need to import the async IO module in Python.
And in a way, it's faster than Express, which is
no GS framework. And Express is the E in the mean
and myrn stacks, as we said. So fast API also
has interactive API documentation. And it helps
you to think the different HTTP requests like
get post put and delete visually using open API,
which is itself based on JSON schema. And I
have a full crash course on fast API, you will
find a card appearing now if you're interested
to check it out. react, of course, is the most
famous JavaScript front end library for building
user interfaces, especially sbas, or single page
applications, as per the Stack Overflow survey
for 2020. React GS is just below jQuery. So as
you can read here that jQuery is still King. But
it's slowly losing ground to react js and angular
year over year as per the most loved framework
is just the second after ASP dotnet core.
And the most wanted actually is react GS the most
wanted in the market. And I believe the link to
the surveys for Stack Overflow in the description
section below. If you would like to check out
other statistics very interesting. You'll find
here that the most dreaded language is VBA.
And I've been working with VB for some time now
at work, especially the debugging system is truly
awful. So no wonder that it's the most dreaded
language. Alright, following that Objective C,
Perl, assembly C, PHP, and so on. So
surprisingly, rust is the most loved language
following that TypeScript then Python, but
actually the most wanted language on the
market is Python, followed by JavaScript them
by go Lang. And I also have a react tutorial
for beginner back end developers, you will find
a card appearing now check it out if you like.
Last, but not least, we need the persistence.
So we'll be using MongoDB, which is the letter M
in form. And I never did a tutorial on MongoDB
on the channel. So this is the first one. And
I'll try to be as much detailed as I can. And I've
received a few requests to create a crash course
on MongoDB and Maria dB. So MongoDB course
is almost ready and will be uploaded soon.
MongoDB is a no SQL database management
system. And no SQL stands for not only SQL,
and it's based on what we call the document model
or collections of documents. So even the normal
SQL system like MySQL, Postgres, or Oracle, if you
have a table if you have a database that consists
of different tables, and each table has some rows
and columns, here in the no SQL world, you have a
collection of documents. And a document is just
the file written in JSON format, and converted
to be sawn or binary JSON, which is the zeros and
ones for the computer to compile and understand.
So in SQL world if you have a database of
different tables, and each table has a set of
rows and columns in mind dB, you have a database
also. But it consists of collections that consists
of documents. And each document has different
fields like ID, name, last name, for instance,
all these are fields in MongoDB document.
Last Word, I would like to say about MongoDB,
that it was created in 2009. And it's the
leading no SQL system on the market now.
So enough me talking, and let's go ahead and
start by creating our application. Our application
basically is a crud application. So the front end
is going to send HTTP requests to the backend,
the backend is going to fetch all the
data from the database in MongoDB,
the MongoDB is going to send the data to fast
API to the back end server, then the back end
server using axios technology will send their
response to the React front end, which you will
be seeing on the screen. So from front end to
back end, the back end to front end. Alright,
you will need obviously to have Python installed,
you will need also no GS because we will need
NPM. In order to create our react application, as
far as MongoDB, you will need to have an account
on MongoDB Atlas. So you can click on Start free.
And you will feel the data here your company
How are using MongoDB, your email,
first name, last name and password.
And once you do that, you will have here
look included with your free cloud database,
you will have one free tier to have a cluster
of computers with 512 megabytes of storage.
Okay, it's just it's not physical computer,
but logical one. So you'll have shared DRAM,
you'll have 512 megabytes of storage, highly
available replica sets, enter an encryption to
meet it patches and REST API. Okay, all of that is
included in your free tier. Alright, so once you
log in, you will not find this in clusters, you
will find a green button in the middle telling
you to create a new cluster. Okay, so this
is cluster zero. This is here how to connect
your collections. And we said that collections
is the equivalent of tables in SQL world can
also have another cluster, but I'm not going to do
it because you're allowed only with one cluster. I
have my region here in Belgium, because I live in
Poland. And I've already tried the one in Germany,
but it was not so efficient. So I created a new
one with Belgium with Google Cloud. Okay, you
will have different options. So let me show you,
you will have Google Cloud you will have is your
I used Google Cloud, as you can see here, and
I use the one you can see here, that free tier
available. Alright, if you're in Brazil, in the
US, and Australia, Finland, all of these are free,
the ones only with a free tier available tag. And
once you know what you want to choose, you can
click on it and create free cluster, I can create
another one because I already have a free tier
free cluster. And you can see here that they
charge you for a second one for zero point $44 per
hour. All right, yeah, but it's just pretty
straightforward. You will choose whatever and
then you will hit on create cluster, it will take
some time to deploy and you will be ready to go.
How you can connect is by clicking on Connect.
And you will have different tools. So you can
connect to your application, you can use the Mongo
shell, which is just a simple terminal to interact
with your database using command line and using
the MongoDB compass, I highly recommend that you
install the compass and the shell. So we're back
to the MongoDB homepage, you can go to software,
click on community server. And you'll find
here on premises, alright MongoDB locally,
so you have MongoDB community server, you
can download that. So MongoDB offers both an
enterprise and community version of its powerful
distributed document database. So don't mind the
enterprise just focus on the community server,
you can download that it's Microsoft installer
MSI file. So this is the first thing you need to
do. Also, you need to go to developer tools. And
here you can download the MongoDB compass and a
MongoDB shell. Okay, so MongoDB compass, and you
can click here on trade now, and it took you back
to the tools and you can download it here. And the
same thing goes to MongoDB shell and if you're
not sure how to do that, please let me know in
the comment section below. And I will create a
quick video to show you how to set up everything
in the path all right in the environment variable
So once everything is installed properly,
you can go ahead and type Mongo D version. And
you will get this DB version 4.46. okay with this
JSON data, K, the version get version, and so
on. Also, to access the MongoDB shell, you can
go ahead and type Mongo s h. And you can take a
look to the available databases. So you can say
show DBS and you will get the default databases
provided by MongoDB. Okay, and let me show you the
MongoDB compass. So this is how it looks like.
So in order to connect, we can say Mongo DB,
colon slash slash 120 7.0. Point 0.1, or
localhost on port 27, zero 17. Click on Connect.
Okay, if you want to create a database, you can
create that easily. Let's say for instance, we'll
have a database with the name of sales. Let's
have a collection of employees, for instance,
okay, and create database. And immediately,
you have your sales database created.
And if you refresh here show DBS, you
will find that the sales has appeared
here. So let's roll up our sleeves and start
by creating our back end server with fast API.
Welcome back. So the first thing that I
want to do is I want to create a folder
that will contain both back end and front end
folders. So let's go to the desktop. And let's
create a folder farm stack underscore project.
First, we will care about the backend folder. So
let's create that. And let's open this with Visual
Studio code. Alright, great. So the first thing
that I want to do here is to create requirements
dot txt. And this is for the dependencies and
will need to have three dependencies. So the
first one is fast API, obviously. So fast API
with version zero, point 65.1. Also, I will
need unicorn. And unicorn is just the fast
as the server implementation that helps in the
interaction between your application that we're
going to build and the backend. So this is the
core of fast API, especially that fast API is in a
synchronous framework, which heavily depends on
a sink await syntax. And therefore the use for
an ASCII server was essential. So the version is
zero. Point 14.0. And also, I will need motor and
motor is 2.4. point zero, which are actually is a
full featured non blocking IO MongoDB driver. So
this works for Python in general. And it's working
with fast API, of course, in our case, and also
works with her native framework. tornador is also
an awesome a synchronous framework. And mature
works with all kinds of async IO applications as
MongoDB driver. So this is what matorral goes.
Alright, so let's go ahead and activate our
virtual environment, or use Pipi and V if you
don't have been v installed, you can install it
via pip install PIP in V. Alright, but I have it
already. So I will not do that. Let's go ahead
and activate that by saying Pipi and V shell.
Alright, great. Now we have our virtual
environment activated and the PIP file
is created. But still, we will need to install
the dependencies. So what we're going to say
is Pipi and V install dash r requirements dot
txt, right and hit Enter. And let's close the
requirements. We don't need that anymore. And
I will need three files. First is main.py.
So main.py, I will need also one for the
database. So we'll call it database.pi.
And the third one for the model, just to create
our main to do class. Alright, so let's go ahead
and start importing from fast API. I want to
import fast with a capital F. API all capitalized.
And also I want to import something very important
which is called course middleware. So from
fast API dot, middleware, dot course. All
right, I want to import course middleware
and course stands for cross origin resource
sharing. I talked a lot about this in all our
Django projects course refers to the
situation when your front end client
Which is running on the browser, it has
naturally JavaScript code. This JavaScript
code communicates with your back end, in our
case communicates with our fast API back end
server. And in this case, the back end is
in a different origin than the front end.
And origins simply is just the combination of
protocol, domain and port. So you can see here
that the protocol can be either HTTP or HTTPS
domain, for example, our localhost or whatever,
and the port might be any port. So react will
have, for example, Port 3000. And our fast API
will have a port of 8000. And we will need some
sort of permission for the back end to interact
with a different origin, a different port in this
case. So this is what we're going to do. Okay, let
me just close that. And let's just instantiate the
fast API class by creating an object called app.
Okay, so this is app object. And here I want
to specify the origins. So in this case,
localhost on port 3000 of react. And if you won't
do this, there will be no connection between both
there will be no permission, okay, for the
headers, the methods, so we will need to allow
headers and methods. Okay, so in the origins,
this is going to be a list with https colon
slash slash localhost colon 3000. Next thing that
we want to do is we want to take our app object,
and we want to add the middleware,
add middleware, this one, okay,
so this method will take first of all, the
course, middleware, course, middleware.
Next, I want to allow origins to be equal
to the origins list. Also the credentials,
we will set it to true, and I want to allow
methods, we will set it to everything or
star. And also we want to allow headers. And let's
just go ahead and create a basic route. So app app
app, this is the creator dot get method and just
type slash, this is an empty route. Basically,
we want to create a method or
function, we'll call it trade routes.
And we want to return something like let's say
ping pong. Alright, so let's check out first if
the main page is working or not. And in order to
run server, we'll say UV corn main app. And I want
to work on our reload mode. So you don't have to
disconnect from the server and reconnect again, in
order to see the changes on the application. This
happens instantaneously once you refresh the page.
Alright, perfect. So let's go ahead and open
that. And we get ping pong. Now the cool thing
about fast API that you can access this
documents called swagger, swagger UI.
And I've talked about this many times in all my
vast API projects on the channel in the course,
I have also another video on vasti, API's
introduction. And I showed everything in
details about the swagger UI, right? So make
sure to check that out. All right, great. So
this is good. But this is useless to us,
it's just to make sure that the server is
responding. So basically, in the to
do application, we need four main,
four main operations write the crud operation.
So we need to read all to dues, we'll need to
post a to do update, and delete. And we can also
get to do by ID, if you want a specific to do
you can get it by its ID. Right. So let's work
on that very quickly. Let's just minimize this
for now and maximize this. So let's have
another decorator dot get. And here we want to
access API slash to do let's now work with a
sink await code. So we will define a method
we will call it get to do and open close paren
column. And for now, we'll say return just one.
So I will need the same code basically, for the
to do by ID. So here I want to have an input of
ID. Alright, so I need the to do by
this specific ID and I will change
the method Naturally, so we're gonna say get to
do is the same by ID. And here I will pass the
ID as a parameter or an input. I also want to
post an ID. So it's the same code as the get.
But instead of gap, we'll change that to
boast. And here we'll say, post to do.
And we will pass the input as to do,
I want also to update and delete,
right, so I will need two more functions.
Okay, selling just organizes a little bit.
So here, I want to update the to do by its
ID. So I will need to enter the ID of the to
do that I would like to modify or edit. And here
I want to change the method will say, put to do
and instead of to do we want the ID because we
want that ID to change. And I want to change
the actual beta of that to do. And, last
but not least, we want to delete out to do,
okay, so, also to do by ID, if we want to access
a specific to do item, and we want to delete it,
so I need to specify the ID for that. And
here, I will change the method, say, delete.
And instead of to do I want to delete
that to do item with that specific ID,
first API object has no Oh, sorry, put, there's
no HTTP request called update, or get post,
put and delete. Alright, so we're good to go.
Let's actually take a look to what we have.
Let's refresh the page. And boom, we have all
the methods that we have created. So we have
get all to dues post or to do get to do by ID, but
to do and delete to do. Alright, perfect. So far,
so good. Now what they want to do is, I want to
go to model.py. And I want to import from pedantic
and pedantic actually helps you to auto
create your JSON schemas from the model.
So we're going to create a class now. And it
works like an object relational mapper. So it will
take from the model, and we'll connect with our
database that we're going to create in a second.
So we want to import B's model class,
then I want to create a class called to do
with Bayes model as a parameter. And I want two
things only I want the title, which is a string.
And I want a description,
description, which is also a string.
And that's all what I need to do. So let's close
model.py. And let's work on our database now.
So here, what I want to do
is to import the to do class
from the model.py. So from model I want to import
to do. And also I want to import the motor module.
So import what or dot motor underscore a sync
i O. Okay, so this is the Mongo DB driver.
All right, and let me just
open the MongoDB campus.
So everything will be clear to you guys. But in
the meantime, I want to create a client object.
And this is going to be equal to one Tor dot
Mordor underscore a sink IO. And I want to access
the async IO model client, this one right here.
And this is essentially for the connection between
the database.pi and Mongo DB. So we will need to
pass in a string, Mongo DB, colon, slash slash,
and local host colon 27, zero 17, which is the
default port for MongoDB. As we said before,
this is column. Alright, so this is a very
important step. And we have our Mongo DB campus is
ready. But we'll leave it for now. Let's continue.
Let's actually create the database I will call it
just a database. And this is going to be equal
to our client dot our database, let's call it
to do list and inside our database, we want
to create The collection. So our collection,
which is the same thing as a table in SQL,
so the collection is going to be equal to
the database. And we want to have a name for
the collection. Let's call it just to do.
Right, so we have a database called to do list.
And we have a collection, which is called to do.
Alright, great. Now let's go ahead
and work on our main functions.
So the first function that I want to create here
is to fetch one to do. So we'll say a sink deaf,
and I'm going to say fetch one to do. And it's
going to take the title as an input. And here, the
document is going to be equal to the collection
dot find one. And I want to specify the title to
be equal to whatever title is going to be entered.
Okay, so the title is set to whatever title here.
and here also, I want to wait for that, right,
and then I want to return that document.
Okay, so this is the first get, so we want
to get one to do. There is no doubt here.
So in order to get one to do we get it by title,
and take a look to model, this is the title or the
ID, which is set in our function in the main.py
file. Okay. So I hope that's clear for you guys.
Next, I want to get all the to
dues. So we'll say def, fetch all
to dues. And I don't want any parameters. And
let's create a list of to dues. And let's declare
a variable called cursor. And cursor is going to
be equal to the collection dot a method called
find. And what we want to do essentially is
to loop over any document in the cursor. So
let's again, use the sink, keyword for document
in cursor, I want to expand in the to dues list,
whatever to do with any document. Okay. So this is
basically the data that I'm going to retrieve, and
I want to return everything in that collection.
And finally, I want to return all the to dues.
Alright, so don't forget that this to do is the
main class that we have defined in the model.py.
Next thing that we want to do is to create a to
do so let's actually create a to do by the finding
create, to do function. And here we want to
take to do as the main parameter or main input.
So the document is going to be equal to
the to do. And oops, what did I do since
then I want to declare a result variable
in order to await for the collection to
insert that document in the collection. So
let's, uh, wait for the collection to
insert one, this is a method called
insert one. And we will insert whatever document
that we're going to create, okay, whatever,
post or whatever to do item that we're going to
create. And also I want to return that document.
Next, we want to update it to do so a sync.
def, and we will call it up date to do and
this takes the title and the description. Okay,
both are set in the model class in the
in the model.py in the to do class. Oh,
okay. And by the way, if you're wondering
what's insert one method, what's that?
Find as well. These are MongoDB functions
or methods. Okay, so we are writing MongoDB
code actually, inside our Python file. So the
motor module which is the MongoDB driver helps us
to connect the database.py file with our MongoDB
database. Alright, so let's get back to our code.
So await the collection to an Another MongoDB
method called update one. So how MongoDB works,
when we want to update one item, we want to choose
a specific item. And in order to do that, we will
need to have a criteria. So which item do we want
to update. In this case, we want to choose by the
title. So the title, whatever title is set to, and
Next, I will have the actual item that I want to
update. So I want to use the set operator
by using the dollar sign set. This is inside
double quotes. And this is set to whatever the
description that I'm choosing, and the actual
description that I'm updating. So we will have
another set of curly braces. And here I want the
description that I have chosen to update for the
actual description that I want to enter or update.
Right, I hope you guys following then I want to
render that document or return that documents. So
I will declare another variable called document to
await the collection dot find one with the title
that corresponds to that item that I have
updated, okay, and will return that document.
Alright, so this is the update to do.
The last method is to delete a to do.
So I'm going to call it remove underscore to do.
And it takes a title as a parameter. So if we
want to delete an item, we should enter the
title first. And let's await for the collection
to delete one, which is another MongoDB method.
And we'll set the title to be equal whatever
is the title that we have entered. And we want
to return a boolean value. And we'll set it
to true. Alright, great. So let's save that.
And let's go ahead to main.pi in order to modify
these functions that we have created based on
these functions in the database file. Right, so
this is 3000, the React JS sport, I want to import
also from fast API HTTP exception. And this is
just for errors and exceptions. So actually, this
class what it does, it generates some exception
information for us. All right, perfect, then
what I want to do now is to import from database,
all the functions that we have created. So let's
actually go to database dot p y. And let's take
this from here, copy. So this is the first one.
Alright, so we have imported the functions from
database file. Next, what we want to do is to work
on these methods. And let's start by the get
to do in order to return just one, we want to
have a response, right. So response is going to
be equal to a weight for fetch all the to dues,
which is there you go. Alright, one of those
functions that we have created in database.pi.
And you can see here that this
actually returns a coroutine.
Right, and I've talked a lot about co routines,
concurrent code concurrency in general,
in different videos before, I will leave
all the links in description below,
you can check them out. So we want to fetch all
the two dues, and we want to return the response.
The second function is to do by title, so
we'll substitute the ID with the title.
Okay, and we want the response model to be
equal to the to do class. So the response model
is equal to the to do class in our model.py file.
In here also, instead of ID, we want a title.
Let's have a response as well. And our
response is going to be equal to fetch
want to do by title and don't forget the await.
And I want to handle exceptions. So I
will say if the response if response
means if response is true. We don't have any
errors. Then we will return the response.
Otherwise, we will raise an HTTP exception. And
this is going to be 404. And the 404 is a status
code four page not found, then what they want to
say is, there is no to do item with this title.
Alright, let's actually make it nicer. So let's
put a format string. And let's return that
title, whatever title that we're trying to
retrieve. So let's move on to the next function,
which is posting to do, I want also the
response model to be equal to the to do
class. And here, I want to set the to do to be
equal to the to do class. And I want to take
that to do take a look, here, we have set the
document to to do, and we are going to insert a
document in the collection. So this is a JSON,
but we want to convert that to a dictionary.
In order to do that, we will declare a variable
called response. And response is going to be equal
to the Create to do function that we have defined.
And I will take the to do and I will convert it to
dictionary. And again, I want some exception
handling. So response, then returned a response.
Otherwise, I want to raise HTTP exception. In
here, we'll say we'll enter 400. Something went
wrong. By the way, 400 is the
status code for bad request,
okay, so you can type something
went wrong or bad request.
Alright, the next function that we want
to modify is put to do so we want to
change the ID by let's actually change all
IDs by title, we will take the response model
also, and we will set it to the to do class. And
for the main function, we want the title, we will
set it to string and also the data, we will set
it to strength and date. Also, we want to change
it to description or desk in the database in the
update function, you see here, title and desk.
So the response is going to be equal to
the update to the function. And this takes the
title and the description. And also it wants
some exception handling. So again, we can take
this one, and we'll paste it here with the same
status code for all four. And last but not least,
we have the Delete function. So let's remove that.
And let's have a response as usual. And we will
take the Remove to do remove to do function.
And we'll remove the item by the title. If you
remember here, we have set the title and also I
want some exception handling. So if response is
returned is okay. We want to return a message
saying successfully deleted to do item. Otherwise,
we want to raise exception, we can take this one.
we'll paste it here. And that's basically it. So
we have the the lead the put the posts, get to do
by the title by ID, and get all to dues. Alright,
cool. We are pretty much done with our database
side. Now let's go ahead and check out the swagger
UI or the fast API docs, and how we can connect it
to the MongoDB database. And we'll see this
interaction with the MongoDB campus. Right
so let's do it. Alright, so we have here our fast
API docs or the swagger UI, where we can interact
with our database. And I have on the other side,
my Mongo campus is opened. And let me show you
until I was connected. Let me Disconnect for the
moment and show you what I did. So as I showed
you at the beginning of the tutorial, you can
copy MongoDB colon slash slash localhost, right?
And connect. And boom, you're connected. And here
you have the to do list that we have created.
And this is because of the motor MongoDB driver.
So let's actually try that out. Let's go ahead and
try to post a to do. So let's say, to do item one.
And in the description, let's say for instance,
walk the dog. Execute, right within have
any problems. So let's check that out
here in the to do list. To do. And boom, we
have to do item one, walk the dog. Alright,
let's reset, cancel, let's close that. And
let's check out here in the gap to dues so
try it out. Execute. And we have the
same to do item one, walk the dog.
Let's have another one, for example posts. And
let's say to do item two, and here, let's say run
two kilometers. Alright, then let's execute.
Okay, cool. Let's refresh here, and boom
to do item to run two kilometres. Alright, so it's
working perfectly, our fast API back end server
is interacting with MongoDB database. Alright,
so let's delete. To do it should be the same
as in the title. So let's say that I want to
delete to do item two. So to do item space to
execute. Alright, successfully deleted to do
item. And if we will refresh, he disappeared.
Alright, so in the next part, we're going to move
on to fleshing out the front end with react js.
Welcome back. So as our back end is working
perfectly and interacting with the MongoDB server,
we will now need to create our front end site,
and we will make it communicate with the back end.
So let's go ahead and create our react app. And I
will use create react app COI for that. But before
we'll need to go to desktop. And we will need
to access farm stack underscore project folder.
Alright, and just to make sure that we have only
one folder, which is the back end. And now we can
use that command NP x, which stands for node
package execute. And I will use create react
app. And for more information about create react
app, please check out the card that will appear
right now. And this will take you to a react and
Django video tutorial for back end developers.
So there I talked a lot about create react
app, what it is and what it's doing for
your project. Following that the name of
the project or the name of the folder,
so we'll call it front end. And the installation
of the project is going to take some time. So I
will pause the video here. And then we'll be back
when it's all done. Alright, cool. So we have our
front end project ready. In order to run it, we
need to see the two front end to change directory
to front end folder, then NPM start. Alright,
great. So this is the default react application,
the development server is running on port 3000
are listening on port 3000. Just before we go on,
I need just to exit the server. And we will need
to install two things. The first is axios. So
sending requests from the client to the server
and getting the responses from the server or
the back end server to the client is the role of
axios. Also we need bootstrap. So boot strap. And
yeah, that's all oops, what did
I do npm install axios bootstrap.
Alright, cool. So let's go ahead and open
the app with Visual Studio code. We just
let's CD out and open the whole
folder with Visual Studio code.
By the way, this j s hint has
been bothering me for some time.
If you have the same issue or if you dealt
with this issue, please let me know because
I've installed GSN globally, but seems that
now I think happened really. But I think it
won't affect our project. So let's ignore that
for the moment. And let's go ahead and import
bootstrap slash dist slash CSS slash bootstrap,
dot min dot CSS. Alright. Just to import bootstrap
this the first thing we need to do index dot j s,
okay. And that's pretty much it for index dot j s,
which is the main entry point for our application,
app dot j, s four, we're going to spend
most of the time I want to chillie get rid
of all that. And let's just type hello world.
formstack. Alright, cool. Let's delete the logo,
we don't need that. So see, even if you have here,
our red line, yellow line truly doesn't affect
anything. We just, it's annoying really.
If you happen to know the solution for this,
please let me know in the comment section below,
because I really couldn't find a suitable
solution to solve this problem. So let's get
rid of everything. We will leave the app. Let
me actually delete all of that. And we'll leave
the app. This is the class name. For the app
application. It has a class name of app. So
here we will have some just general settings.
So the text align, we'll leave it to the center.
margin, we'll give it zero padding, we'll set it
to zero, and font family, we will use this one.
Alright. And that's all. So we'll close the app
dot CSS. And let's go ahead and work on the app
file. So I'll just delete that. Or we'll leave
it just we'll leave it just for sanity check.
So before we do anything, we will need to import
react first, right, so it just make this bigger
for you guys. So we will import react. Also, we
will need two functions use state and use effect
from react. We also want to import axios from
axios. And also we want to import the bootstrap.
So let's go here. We'll import bootstrap.
Let's first work on the visual side, then
we will work on the logic. So let's go ahead
and have a div with a class name of app with
lists group item. These are bootstrap classes.
Also, we want to justify content center
align items center with a horizontal margin
set to auto. So in order to add styling
to JSX, we will have double curly braces
and inside you can enter whatever style
that you want. So I want to set the width
to 400 pixels. And also I want the background
color to be white, and the margin top to be 15
pixels. And inside the div I will have a title
with h1 tag, we will call it Task Manager.
Alright, great. So this has a class name of card
with text white primary background, which is the
blue one and margin bottom set to one below the
task manager I want to add h6 tag with three words
fast API, react and MongoDB. Then I will have
another div with a class name of card body. Inside
that main Dave, I want to have an h5 tag with a
class name of card and I will say add your task.
This has a dark background with margin bottom
three, and the text is white to have the contrast.
The next thing that I want to do is to create two
input fields, one for the title and the other one
for the description and a button This button
is to add your task. So in order to do that,
I will wrap everything around a span this
span will have a class name of card text.
So this is the first input and this is
the second input for the description.
So both they have MB two or margin bottom two
with form control with different names, title
in and d s in and both they have placeholders so
one with title and the other one with description.
The next element in our
application is the Add task button.
So it has a class name of btn with btn outline
primary. Alright, so I've given it a border radius
with 50 pixels to give it that rounded shape
around the button. And also set the font weight to
bold. And this is everything inside the span. So
the idea here is when you will enter the title and
the description, and you will add the task, the
task will appear below here with one button only,
which is the Delete below the span. And
on the same line with the add your task
h5 tag, I want to add another h5 tag with
your tasks, let's actually give the button
some margin bottom in order to have some space. So
MB, we'll set it to two, that's better. And then
what we want to do is to display all of your to do
is below your tasks. Alright, so let's have a div.
Inside that div, we should plug all of our
to do items. And this should be an external
component. And down here below, I
want to create a copyright mark.
And you're free to change the colors if you want.
Of course, this has a background of warning,
which is the yellow one, right? With a class
of card decks dark BG warning, padding why on
the vertical axis with one and margin bottom of
zero, just don't forget to delete that Dave below.
And that one, because I've written it again. Okay.
So it's the same thing. Once we save, nothing
will change. Alright, so before we move on and
create our components folder with the different
components, there are a couple of things that we
need to do in our function. The first thing we
need to do is to create different variables,
one for the to do list, one for the title,
and another one for the description,
and all of them will be set to use date.
So set to do list will be set to use date with
an array of empty object. And inside here,
we will append the items each time you will add a
task. Also, we will set the title. And we'll use
the state for just anti strained, nothing for the
moment, the same thing goes for the description.
And once you add a title and description, hit
Add task, everything here will change. So this
is the usefulness of use state function. The next
thing we want to do is to read all the to dues
for that I will use use effect method. And we'll
use use effect in order to accept the HTTP request
methods like get post and so on. So the first
thing we want to do is to read all of the to
dues. And this, what we'll do is that it will send
a get request to the fast API back end server,
okay, then, this callback will return a promise
and we handle promises with that then, and having
a response as an input, we should access all
the data inside that input, or the response.
All right, and all of that is wrapped inside the
set to do list that we have defined here above.
And the last thing we need here is to post a to
do to add a task actually when we click on the Add
task button. So this add to do handler variable,
which is set to a callback function, which doesn't
take anything as an input, returns that post
request. So the first parameter is the origin.
So HTTP localhost Port 8000 for the API and to
do, and we want to display the title for whatever
title it is, and the same for the description.
And then we have a callback as a response
that goes for the response as an input, and we
can console log rez or we can just alert dress,
this is just for verification step. Now what
we'll need to update both input fields and the
Add task button. Alright, so the first input field
which concerns the title, we will update it with
the on change attribute, this takes and event as a
parameter, then it returns set title which we have
set here above and inside the set title we have a
parameter of event dot target dot value, the same
exact thing goes for input. So input
also we will have on change attribute
with an event that set the description for
event dot target dot value. Last but not least,
we have the button so for to button we have
apt to do handler function here. So the button
should be updated in order to reflect the changes
that will occur when we click on the button. And
don't forget to re add the margin bottom three in
order to push the your tasks a little bit below.
So this is pretty much everything that we need
to do for Abdo j s The last thing that we need
to do do is to add the to do items inside both
div tags. So let's go ahead to our source folder.
And let's create a folder called components. And
inside components, I will create a file I will
call it to do dot j s, and another file called
to do list view dot j, s To Do List View dot j s.
First of all, let's go to to do and let's import
axios and react. Now I want to create a to do item
function that it will take as a parameter props.
Inside that function, I will declare a variable
called Delete to do handler, and I will set this
to a callback function that takes title as a
parameter in order to delete whatever to do item
that we want to specify by the title. And what we
want to return actually is the item itself. And
next to that item, we will have a delete button.
So you can see here we have a div with a
paragraph span with a style. And we will enter
or we will plug the props.to do dot title. So
the title first, and this is going to be bold,
then a colon, and then we want to have the
description next to it. And then after we'll
have a button with onClick attribute is going
to be set to a callback function which doesn't
take anything as a parameter, and it will return
to the lead to do handler function that we have
created above here. Again, it will take props.to
do the title. And why is that because we want to
search that item in function of title. So
the main criteria for deletion is the title,
also will will have a class name with a
button. And all of that is again bootstrap
classes. So now we have our to do dot j s
ready, we want to import that in the to do
list views dot j s. But before we do that, we need
first to export the to do item function. Alright,
in order to import it in the to do list view
dot j s, so we will import the to do item from
current directory. Where is the to do dot j
s. Alright, and then I will need the function
that I'm going to plug inside my app dot j s
here. So all the items that will appear below
should be created in our to do ListView dot j
s. So let's go ahead and create that function,
we'll call it to do view and
he takes props as a parameter.
And what it will return simply a ul or unordered
list. And the props.to do list dot map which is
one of the array methods like reduce filter and
sort. And we're going to map whatever to do and
plug it inside that to do item. So that to do item
that we have imported from the to do dot j s here.
Alright, so this is how it's working.
And let's not forget to export it.
So in order to test everything together,
let's go ahead and open our back end server.
So we'll go to back end.
And UV corn main app load.
Okay, good. So it's listening on port 8000. So
if we will refresh the page. Okay, cool. Just
make this a little bit bigger, there is something
very important that we forgot to do is to import
the to do view from the to do list. Alright,
so we'll need to do that below the bootstrap.
And now instead of that comment,
we will add our actual to do
item. Alright, perfect. So we have our front end,
running on that instance of the terminal. And we
will need also to open a new terminal instance
for the back end. So unicorn main app, reload.
Okay, great. So let's open our fast API swagger.
Alright, so for the moment, our database doesn't
hold any data. So this collection has no data, as
you can see here in the MongoDB report. On this
side, we have our back end server, our fast API
server. This is the React application, our client,
and here we have our database server, our MongoDB
database server. So let's try to add a to do item.
So we'll say to do one, study rust language. At
ask ambu to do one study rust language. Alright,
and if we will refresh here, we will have this
document created in our database. So we'll have an
ID, which is very similar to the primary key
in the SQL world. This is auto generated by
MongoDB. We'll have our title and description.
Right, let's try to add another one to do to
run 10 kilometers at dusk, refresh,
the same sleep at 9pm, add task,
refresh, and so on. So you can see what's
happening. It will delete, let's say, to do to
delete it from here, refresh, it will disappear.
Let's add another one. So let's say to do for
sketching at dusk. So it adds below. And if you
will go to the backend, you will find the same
information. So let's try to access actually API
slash to do and you will find all of our to dues.
All right, everything here. Similarly in the docs,
when you will hit when you will click on
get to do try it now or try it out. Execute,
you will find your two dues. This JSON
format right and let's refresh that as well.
So to be identical Okay, so this was an
introduction to the farm stack and how
we can work with the three technologies.
If you liked the video, please like it,
share and subscribe to the channel. And I
appreciate your support guys. Thank you very
much. If you have any questions, please let me
know in the comments section below. Take it easy